a truly gorgeous afternoon for baseball
now from sunny AT&T Park in San
Francisco ought to be a good one here
between the San Francisco Giants and the
Los Angeles Dodgers should see some
great battles out of these two next on
the show
clayton kershaw a Texas born left-hander
against the starting nod ek what's the
word on him Bo guys remember he's got
five pitches to work with so that really
makes it difficult for the hitter he can
change speeds ball moving in and out not
a lot of fun for the hitters Denard Span
makes his way to the plate then we are
ready for some daytime baseball or San
Francisco
center fielder Denard Span and the first
pitch of the afternoon is taken for ball
one and we're underway from San
Francisco first pitch one equipment
and a strike to even the count one in
one yeah I don't think you want to come
in throwing a lot of high change ups
that's a pitch he's gonna have to get
lower in the strike zone Kershaw gets
the sign 1-1 on its way
broken bat is this balls hit on the
ground throw on to first we'll take care
of spam for the game's first out and
he's out of the visiting San Francisco
Giants lineup in this one who's the one
to watch ek well we'll see if Hunter
Pence can keep swinging a hot stick he's
got some wheels on him and that's a big
part of why he's successful at the major
league level a routine grounders become
tough plays singles get turned in and
doubles and what would have been a 1-2-3
inning suddenly becomes a rally Joe
Panik comes on with one way as he looks
at a ball it's one a no so let's take a
peek at the umpiring crew in this one
behind the plate is Matthew Ross well
Matt with Ross behind the plate hitters
know they need to expand the strike zone
a little bit he likes to ring it up when
it's on the black or even a little off
of it in the air out to right there to
make the play is Puig for round number
two
and with that let's look at how the
Dodgers align on defense it's brought to
us
my into the right side and that's in
their base hit and they won't risk it at
third so they're at the corners now with
only one away boy how about that bat
from your pitchers fan you started
thinking this is already a really good
at-bat because he's seen so many pitches
but then he caps it off by finishing it
with a base hit Denard Span will get a
second shot now he grounded out to start
the ballgame not really a good app out
there forget getting out but he didn't
see any pitches as well
first pitch of the at-bat he slaps that
one away and the count will be nothing
in one
Oh in one count and the pitch swinging
he pops him up over toward foul
territory and he'll stay with it to put
it away as they get their man here for
the second out pretty well struck high
and deep to left field back goes begun
he tracks it down and makes the play to
record the second out
yasiel puig makes his way to the plate
noon to make something happen they're
down to their final out in the ninth
inning that's not looking too good for
him anymore but you know what there's no
clock in this sport and that's for good
reason you got to fight for all 27 out
line hard toward right-center lays out
and he makes a spectacular catch what a
way to end this one and how about that
for putting an exclamation point on
victory just a super play there to
record the final out with some style